so i have to to comment on your t-shirt
i think it says immigrants feed
uh america which i could not agree more
with
and you have such an incredible personal
narrative yourself
you came to this country with next to
nothing
uh you worked in a restaurant i know
you've been back and forth
to spain and the u.s but you you your
work
uh just kept on drawing more and more
fans and support and uh everywhere you
went people
um wanted to to taste your food really
but you know is so much of it uh and i
feel like your
immigrant story is like the story that
so many people came to this country
to have a chance at themselves just to
try and create a better life for
themselves and their families
uh and you know i'm the son of
immigrants myself
and you know i know you've had your
run-ins with our current president
hopefully outgoing president over the
fact that you were supposed to have a
restaurant
in one of his establishments and then
you said you know what i don't think i
want to have
a restaurant in this establishment and
and ended up
like on the other side of the the
president
there which i i commended your or
like i like many americans thought that
you were awfully
uh principled and courageous to make
that stand um
but i'm sure there were some negative
effects uh as well that you had to deal
with
well let me tell you imagine the day i
wake up and
uh the president of united states is
suing
my company and myself personally and
actually
because that was the right thing to do i
saw him back
how many times you have a president of
the united states that is in a zoo with
a citizen
i think he's a first um but i did it
because i
i sincerely believe that
that his comments on mexicans were used
uh not the right thing to be listening
from a leader um
and and that the right thing to do was
to stand up
many people told me if you knew he will
become president will you do the same as
a hundred times over yes
i remember speaking with him uh in the
um early days of his comments and he
told me don't worry he said everything
will be fine
jose we are winning jose we are winning
i say
mr trump i'm i'm trying to open a
restaurant
i'm not running in your ticket uh i'm
not
supporting your ticket i only want to
have a successful restaurant
and i believe that we the people uh
means that we should be respecting each
other it doesn't seem you're a person
that respect others and and i hope that
you will change and rephrase
uh your comments i thought he was going
to do something i was so naive
that i thought that a cook like me an
immigrant like me could
make a person like him maybe to
sound apologetic i don't think that was
naive at all jose
i like like it was quite reasonable of
you to think that
he doubled down two weeks later and he's
a mom and dad
so for me obviously you mentioned about
matured immigrants immigration reform
listen as an immigrant and as a
spanish-american
i'm very thankful about the amazing
opportunity
i gained by being invited to join this
country
and by becoming american you gain
a lot of a lot of things that this new
country of ours gives us
but with with with the with becoming
american
also you gain responsibilities to be a
good citizen
to give back to respect others and to
give back
as much as we receive from the country
that welcome us
but also we need to be aware of the big
lie that we have on immigration reform
that we need to be also pragmatic we had
chances with the democratic party that
we didn't take
and and is everybody needs to be
involved in passing
immigration reform dreamers is the first
step how is possible that we have almost
a million
uh americans because they may not have a
passport but to me
sometimes you don't belong to a place
because they give you a paper
you belong a place because you work hard
to belong
those dreamers they are earn our respect
by becoming young citizens almost a
million
is strong do you know how long it takes
to train a workforce of a million
people this is an asset for america
i always say that the immigration reform
is not a problem for america to solve
it's an opportunity for america to cease
dreamers should be part of the american
dream
today but who people think
is being feeding america through this
pandemic
the people that are that we can afford
to be playing golf who do you think is
taking care of those golf courses
who do you think is refilling the
shelves who do you think is working the
farms
every day from sunrise to sunset
sometimes badly paid badly treated
without any ppe to make them
safe who do you think is the people that
they've been
putting america forward through this
entire pandemic
many americans in the in the middle
lower class that they've been working
day in and day out to provide for their
families but indirectly
to keep america moving but 11 million
undocumented americans i am telling you
they've been in every corner
of america through this pandemic moving
america forward
those men and women they show the value
to america they
show that they belong to america is
about time that once and for all
we pass comprehensive immigration reform
america will win
republicans and democrats will win
because we all know and undocumented
they are part of our lives our our
communities
it's about time we do this and i hope
this pandemic towards 2021
will give the opportunity one day soon
enough to pass
immigration reform to allow dreamers to
belong and become american citizens and
why not to give the opportunity to
undocumented
uh immigrants to have a legal status in
this country
uh it's heartbreaking that we have
missed the opportunities we've had jose
you know that there were windows when
bipartisan legislators came forward and
said we need
a comprehensive approach to immigration
and everyone knows it
unfortunately many politicians now
feel like it's more advantageous to them
to have something to
make people upset uh than it is to
to reach across the aisle and hammer out
like some kind of compromise or
bipartisan approach
and we're seeing that in on multiple
fronts unfortunately now with a pandemic
but immigration to me has to be
very very high on that list of things
that americans know that
we need needed years ago to have
a more rational approach uh humane
approach
a more clear-eyed approach for the
reality of the fact that so many of our
communities rely upon
immigrants every single day and so your
t-shirt's very apt
it's so inspiring to me to see someone
like you who's come here
made so much of yourself but then also
thrown yourself into
multiple important causes right now
fighting for restaurant tours
uh for immigrant rights but also you've
led many humanitarian efforts around
food and food scarcity and food relief
we need a white house that recognizes
the problem we're facing
and when you have a leader that seems
not even to recognize
we have a pandemic and seems not to
recognize
how many businesses are suffering and
who instead of coming up with the smart
ideas and bills
to invest into solutions seems is
throwing money at the problem
we've been paying farmers across america
the big farmers
because very bad policy in
the white house fight with china where
actually now
we are not better off uh maybe the
president is showing uh
everybody how strong he is against china
but right now we've
spending more money paying subsidies to
our farmers that they are not even
producing food
because the war with china we've spent
four or five times
in those subsidies to farmers that we
spend when we had the
automobile crisis and is not creating
jobs
is only throwing money the problem the
president looks good but he's really
writing checks to farmers
in the process we're not feeding america
this is to me
insane that's why we need policies
that they don't look that they're good
so you can get boats
on election day but policies that
empower
americans to do well all across
we need a white house that recognizes
the pandemic until we don't have that
leadership in place everything is going
to be hard
because we require a very big
approach idea to have a big investment
to regrow the economy towards 2021 2022
and right now i don't see that
leadership in the white house or in the
senate
well you know i'm on board jose that we
need a different
uh set of leaders in the white house and
uh hopefully we can turn the page
for our country on november 3rd or
thereabouts
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you